if it makes you feel any better I never
had an orgasm until I was 42 and then
when I did it lasted till I was 44. 43
was
I got nothing done
so
how are you awesome I am dating a lot of
guys good a lot black guys mostly Kelly
what
oh big strong man fancy new whatever I
don't think you ever cared about me I
never cared about you six months ago
Karen filipelli sent me an email asked
me out I said no because I was committed
to our relationship well I hope you're
still committed because I'm pregnant
where is that bad cat oh you know who
you are excuse me petal I'm looking for
Mr Ash
he's a bad bad cat
you're bad no you look at me when I talk
to you do you hear me Mr Ashley look at
me
[Music]
this is getting weird
is she cleaning the cat with her tongue
oh
[Music]
has this been on the entire time I have
no idea
I was looking at
pictures of boot on my computer
oh sorry I'm late
I want to get that image out of my head
psychological issues that go behind
licking a cat are not things I want to
go into
also I'm pretty sure she caused a bear
ball what about this one
it's kind of badass right
just seems kind of crazy in a way I
might need right now I don't know oh
that's not yours
Stanley just drank OJ out of my mug and
didn't seem to realize that it wasn't
his hot coffee
so the question has to be asked is there
no limit to what he won't notice
what's a seven-letter word for purse
actual no starts with an H handbag
thank you
all right everybody take a seat as you
may have heard our branch on the planet
Jupiter is up eight thousand percent in
sales
[Applause]
hold up my clock is slow it is five
o'clock I will see you all tomorrow bye
Stanley love you
so long Stanley all right everybody
eat it you don't have to do that Kevin I
don't know I'm glad this is happening
thank you Michael
why are you eating stem first this is a
new food for me how well should I eat it
the other way
can I get some cheese whiz or
hollandaise no no cheese whiz no
hollandaise no chocolate sauce just eat
it come on here comes the airplane there
you go open open into the hanger there
you go yep eat it
put it in your mouth and just eat it I
don't care whether you hate it you say
you do it all right eat it eat it
you're killing him Michael all right all
right all right
I ate some fluffy Park can I be yum let
me see if you swallowed it over your
mouth
under your tongue oh God
Creed yes sir
everything okay everything's cool dude
I'm 30.
well in November I'll be 30. hey
Meredith I talked to you privately for a
second about what your outfit
what what's wrong with my outfit
you might consider pulling it down a
touch
writing up a little high
a bunch of fruits you know Oscar's
allowed to wear sandals but I'm not a
little more open to a shoes is that the
how it goes Meredith your boob is out
fine
too far damn it Meredith where are your
panties casual day
happy
oh Toby
everyone now that we have all this
energy why don't we move a copier into
the annex like we've always wanted to
hey so long noise one two three
oh and we have torn up the Cobb Hill
we're gonna be in so much trouble wait
it's beautiful Hardwood
I always knew it was down here I just
never dreamed that I would actually see
it
though
you were toxic you are toxic Kelly okay
I have a few things to say to you please
don't interrupt I wasn't going to enter
maybe you do a lot so just don't thank
you I know that I haven't always treated
you the way that you for whatever reason
feel you deserve to be treated
but I want to marry you Kelly Kapoor
Maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but someday
and probably barf
what is your problem hey hey hey hey can
we turn this back around quickly please
can we turn this around quickly this is
very important to me turn around
turn around please
[Music]
just me
and I'm also sorry that a lot of people
here for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
that was an overreaction
hit the break room does anybody want
anything
man you good
sure okay
foreign
[Music]
you know what
I don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist BFD I'm a screenwriter
and I'm a Candle Maker but you don't
hear me bragging about it no all you do
is you get me to try to work on my rich
friends
opportunity man I would love to burn
your candles you burn it you buy it oh
but I'll be your first customer you're
hardly by first
foreign
[Music]
good luck paying me back on your zero
dollars a year salary plus benefits babe
what if we all get together and help
each other and hire a new guy and then
we all kill him but first we take out
like a hundred thousand dollar life
insurance policy I bet you guys like
that idea don't you
I think that's what they're doing to me
I can't prove it but I wanted to see
their faces when I said it I learned
nothing
I don't know what that was oh no no Jada
what are you doing
oh so sorry guys I hope my family didn't
disrupt your meeting Daddy are these the
people who are making you manager
maybe sweetheart
single dad challenges
I don't know if he'd be a good manager
but he's a really great dad okay this
was mistake
actually it's kind of too bad we're not
coming into work tomorrow why I bet
Michael had some elaborate theme party
planned like scrambled eggs Saturday
I'm like hey everyone let's get your
boss laid Saturday
[Laughter]
I have an announcement uh to make I am
moving to Costa Rica thought about it
for a long time now
and I'm finally going to do it
so
I'm just gonna hop the fence and Jog
home now